the simpsons has been around for so long
the series can be used to mark the
passage of time in fact
plenty of the show's current viewers
were born after it debuted in 1989.
if you're one of these fans check out
the most popular episode from the year
you were born
the most popular episode of the simpsons
to air in 1989
was also the only one to air that year
of course we're talking about
simpsons roasting on an open fire the
very first full-length episode of what
is now the longest running show in prime
time history
it's a classic simpsons tale about homer
bumbling through life in order to make
his family happy
and it's packed with relatable moments
hilarious disappointments and cutting
satirical humor
early in the story the simpsons
christmas celebration is put in serious
jeopardy when power plant owner mr burns
chooses fat
executive raises over holiday bonuses
for employees
homer doesn't tell marge the bad news
because he thinks he can dip into a big
jar of money she has stashed in her hair
unfortunately marge ends up using this
emergency fund
on laser skin surgery for bart after he
gets a tattoo when her back is turned
forced to take on a second job for the
holidays homer becomes a lackluster mall
santa he only ends up earning 13
and decides to bet it all at the dog
track where he promptly loses
everything but fear not this first
simpsons episode has a happy ending
after the race the losing dog that homer
bet on jumps into his arms
and bart asks if they can keep him he's
a loser
he's pathetic he's
a simpson in 1990 the simpsons was just
about the hottest thing on television
and bart quickly became the breakout
star so it's not surprising that he
served as the centerpiece of the show's
second season premiere
bart gets an f which was also the most
popular episode of the year
appropriately enough this installment
forces bart to reckon with his immature
decisions in bad boy ways
after faking his way through a book
report on treasure island which he
didn't bother to read
in cheating off of milhouse on a test
the school psychiatrist tells homer in
marge that it would be best for bart to
repeat the fourth grade
ded said against it bart actually tries
to improve his marks
and gets class brain martin to tutor him
in exchange for popularity lessons
after forcing himself to study bart
defies everyone's expectations and does
well enough on a history test to pass
though he just barely scores a d-minus
still it was enough to earn his test a
coveted place on the fridge
right next to one of lisa's many eggs
viewers can pick up clues from early
episodes of the simpsons that homer and
marge are in their late 30s and met at
springfield high school
the 1991 flashback episode the way we
was
provides a lot more detail by depicting
the story of homer and marge's first
days as a couple
the idea of a simpsons episode set in
the 70s featuring a young homer in march
was irresistible and the way we was
ended up as the most watched episode of
1991
back in 1974 high school senior homer
lands in detention yet again
for smoking in the boys room studious
marge winds up there for the first time
because she burned a bra at a feminist
rally
when she walks into detention it's love
at first sight for homer and he
immediately wants to ask her to the prom
to get close to march he hires her as
his french tutor
despite not actually taking that class
after an undeniable chemistry develops
between them
and she accepts his prom invite he lets
it slip that he lied about french class
feeling betrayed marge goes to the prom
with handsy nerd artie ziff instead
standing up a heartbroken homer at the
end of an awful night for both of them
marge picks up homer off the side of the
road and they share their first
fate sealing kiss while lisa's first
word
prominently features lisa as a baby the
real reason this is the most viewed
episode of 1992
is that it was a huge milestone in the
life of maggie
in the run-up to this episode's airing
fox heavily hyped the fact that
hollywood legend and academy award
winner elizabeth taylor would guest star
as the voice of mackie
towards the beginning of the story the
simpsons move into their home on
evergreen terrace but that's just the
first of many changes in store for the
family
bart is also forced to contend with a
creepy clown bed that homer made
because he needs to give up his crib for
the newly born lisa
the new addition gets so much of his
parents attention that bart starts
acting out and threatens to run away
but he's stopped in his tracks when lisa
says her first word
bart at the end of the episode the
action returns to the present where
homer puts maggie to bed
telling her he's in no rush for her to
speak because he doesn't want her to
talk back
after he leaves the room maggie delivers
the moment everyone was waiting for
tacky
it's no secret that homer is a man of
simple pleasures
especially when it comes to alcohol but
in duffles
the most popular episode of 1993 homer
pays the price for his endless love of
beer
as the story begins homer sneaks out of
work to take the duff brewery tour with
barney
naturally they both have a few samples
rendering barney physically unable to
drive
homer who didn't indulge as much as
barney gets behind the wheel and is
immediately busted by chief wiggum
charged with drunk driving homer is
stripped of his license
and forced to attend alcoholics
anonymous meetings
my name is homer and i'm just here
because the court made me come
homer with our help you'll never touch a
beer again
[Music]
marge worried about homer's addictive
behaviors thinks giving up beer for a
month might be a good idea for him
he reluctantly agrees and though it's
extremely difficult he eventually
succeeds
in the process he saves a hundred
dollars and loses so much weight that he
no longer sweats while eating
at the end of the month homer even
resists his urge to down a few beers at
the bar
instead he goes on a romantic bike ride
with marge
let's just hope he didn't end up taking
her to moles
the simpsons annual halloween specials
are a tv tradition
that still endures to this day in 1994
the phenomenon reached critical mass as
treehouse of horror 5
ranked as the most viewed episode of the
year the episode starts with a parody of
the horror classic the shining where mr
burns
hires the simpsons to be the winter
caretakers of his remote mountain lodge
but he makes sure to get rid of all the
beer and tv sets
sending homer into a murderous rage then
in time and punishment
homer tries to fix the family's toaster
and accidentally turns it into a time
travel device
after going back way too far and
squishing a prehistoric insect
homer zaps his way through various
bizarre timelines created by his actions
including a ned flanders rule dystopia
the episode finishes out with nightmare
cafeteria
in this segment principal skinner helps
lunch lady doris figure out new ways to
serve the kids on a budget
are you saying you killed jimbo
processed his carcass and served him for
lunch
while the owner of springfield's nuclear
power plant mr burns is famously cruel
the 1995 episode who shot mr burns part
1
demonstrates just how low the wicked
tycoon is willing to sink
after oil is discovered under
springfield elementary school
bringing much needed funds to the poorly
resourced institution
burns steals the lucrative crude with
his slant drilling company
not only does he destroy large parts of
the town in the process
including the springfield retirement
castle and mohs tavern
he creates a monopoly on energy forcing
everyone in the region to get their
power from burns sources
by the end of the episode burns has been
shot by an unknown assailant
and is barely clinging to life while
sprawled out on a sundial
of course this is only part one of the
simpsons most famous cliffhanger
which left the world wondering who shot
mr burns
well i couldn't possibly solve this
mystery can
you
yeah i'll give it a shot two years after
earning some of its biggest halloween
ratings ever
another simpsons frightfest treehouse of
horror seven
scared up enough viewers to rank as the
top episode of 1996.
some of the interest in this episode
might have been influenced by that
year's presidential race which was
between bill clinton and bob dole
the simpsons always a satirical show
made fun of both candidates in his
halloween special by having recurring
alien invaders kang and kodos abduct the
two men
take over their bodies and run for
president in their place
as the aliens point out the united
states has a two-party system
so americans have to vote for one of
them and then wind up enslaved
in the anthology episode's other
segments lisa's tooth in a petri dish
experiment leads to a rapidly evolving
society where she is worshiped
and in the final story the family
confronts hugo bart's monstrous twin
brother who's been kept chained up in
the simpsons attic
fox was responsible for more than a few
hits that dominated pop culture in the
1990s but only one dared cross over with
the simpsons
the x-files bringing fbi agents fox
mulder and dana scully to the simpsons
was at its core a publicity stunt and it
worked like
gangbusters the springfield files was
the most popular episode of 1997.
one night a very drunk homer walks home
from moe's tavern and stumbles into the
woods where he comes face to face with
something completely unexplainable
a wispy glowing big-eyed creature
resembling popular depictions of aliens
news of the encounter reaches mulder and
scully and they journey to springfield
to investigate the mysterious sighting
eventually it's not the x-files duo that
cracks the case
but lisa she forces smithers to come
forward
and explain that the presumed alien is
actually the elderly and decrepit mr
burns
it turns out that his weekly life
preserving medical treatments leave him
so confused and disoriented that he
wanders around the woods
the glow is simply a side effect from
working around nuclear power for so long
in bart carney the best performing
episode of 1998 the simpsons explore the
sketchy world of traveling carnivals
when the carnival comes to springfield
and the family decides to check it out
bart gets himself into trouble almost
immediately
he hijacks a car that the carnival
claims once belonged to adolf hitler
and smashes it into a tree to pay for
the damages
bart and homer become carnies under the
tutelage of father-son carney duo cooter
and spud
the simpson guys learn all about fixing
games and bribing police
although homer fails to properly pay off
chief wiggum despite his many hints
this gets cooter and spud's game shut
down which is also where they live
taking pity on them homer invites them
to stay with the family
he soon learns that he shouldn't have
trusted the two carnies before long
they temporarily assume ownership of the
house and won't let the simpsons back in
you can't do this to me what about the
carny code
[Laughter]
in maximum homer drive the most watched
episode of 1999 homer is intrigued by a
promotional stunt at a steakhouse
whoever can eat a 16-pound steak with
all the trimmings gets it for free
he then accepts a challenge from a
long-haul truck driver named red
broccoli
who bets homer that he can finish the
huge meal before he does
red is the first to polish off his steak
but in the process
he dies of what dr hibbert diagnoses as
beef poisoning
homer taking all the wrong lessons from
this experience decides there's only one
thing to do
complete red's last delivery with bart
by his side
of course he does this without knowing
how to drive a big rig or
understanding the culture of the road i
want you to blow your horn
oh
that little punk it's a little
surprising that it took until the
simpsons 12th season for trickster bart
to become a professional con artist
fans were apparently eager to experience
this foregone conclusion firsthand as
the great money caper was the top
episode of 2000.
at the beginning of the story a sturgeon
falls from a space station and crashes
into the simpsons car
after that unexpected event bart and
homer decide to bust as a magic act
so they can earn enough money to fix the
family car this game doesn't go
according to plan
and the duo only earns 60 cents homer
quickly loses his patience with bart and
drives away without him
when passerby take pity on the boy he
starts raking in the cash without having
to do anything
after bart takes a taxi home and buys
himself a steak dinner
both simpson guys realized that they
could just griff people to earn money no
busking skills required
naturally it all goes bad and eventually
homer and bart get caught by an fbi
agent
but even that is a ruse the agent is in
fact
an actor hired by march to teach homer
and bart a lesson
the 2001 episode homer attempts to
explain why the simpsons dad has such a
unique personality
to put it kindly fans were so eager to
learn how he got to be so homer-like
that they made it the most watched
episode of the year after homer gets a
job as a medical test subject
doctors find a crayon lodged in his
brain it turns out that when homer was a
child
he shoved 16 of them up his nose he
thought that he had sneezed them all
out but one stubborn crayon stuck around
for decades
after houma has it surgically removed
his unencumbered brain
finally works correctly in fact homer
suddenly becomes intelligent
cultured and able to relate to brilliant
lisa for once
they even go to the library together
however after a few ups and downs
homer realizes that he was much happier
when he was less intelligent
luckily mo is more than willing to
hammer the crayon back into his brain
and restore homer's previous level of
intelligence
extended warranty how can i lose perfect
large marge from 2002 is absolutely
packed with silly psych acts
which helped it become the most popular
episode of the year
for example when lisa wins a bet with
homer and gets to choose their daddy
daughter day activity
she has them build houses for domiciles
for the destitute they work alongside
ex-presidents bill clinton
george bush and jimmy carter who engage
in three stooges-esque physical comedy
and violent slapstick
later at the work site homer
demonstrates to a couple women how marge
birth bark
only for her to drive by and think that
he is flirtatiously flexing his muscles
for them
worried that homer is losing his passion
for her marge decides to get liposuction
unfortunately the surgeons mix up their
patients and provide the episode with
its central plot line
and its most obvious psychic what on
earth have you done
my mcguppies became bazangas
in 2003's i'm spelling as fast as i can
two big events simultaneously pass
through the greater springfield area
a championship spelling competition and
a mania for krusty burger's rib rich
of course homer gets addicted to the rip
witch a sandwich whose meat source is
couched in secrecy
he joins a group of rib heads who travel
around to different krusty burger
locations
according to the sandwich's rolled out
release schedule homer's new adventure
in gluttony comes to an abrupt end when
krusty announces that the ribwitch will
be discontinued as the animal from which
it's derived has suddenly gone extinct
meanwhile lisa quickly rises through the
ranks of competitive spelling in a
surprise twist
writer george clinton asks lisa to throw
the finals to a more popular remarkable
competitor named alex
if she goes along with the plan she'll
receive a full college scholarship
and a george clinton hot plate lisa of
course sticks to her high morals and
announces during the competition
that she was asked to throw the contest
she then defiantly continues to compete
sadly she then misspells her word and
knocks herself out of the finals
still her family is incredibly proud of
lisa and her second place finish
you're the number one speller in this
car or in dead car
or in that car or you don't look at that
guy
building fighting robots is an ongoing
pastime for thousands of people
but in the early 2000s the pursuit
enjoyed a mainstream moment with shows
like battlebots
the simpsons tapped into this fad in
2004 and it paid off
the robot theme story i do bot
was the most popular episode of the year
after houma does a terrible job of
assembling bart's new bicycle
he decides to make it up to him by
constructing a battlebot to compete on
the tv show
robot rumble homer's not the most
talented engineer however
and resorts to crafting a glorified
robot costume
he places himself inside then goes on
television and suffers through many
violent beatdowns until bart finally
discovers what his dad has been up to
but this doesn't stop homer he continues
to fight until the true finally pops out
that robot has given birth to a man
in 2005 fox had the rights to the super
bowl
and gave the simpsons the honor of
airing a special episode right after the
big game
that installment homer and ned's hail
mary pass
seems like it was custom made to retain
as many sports fans as possible
and it clearly worked since it was the
year's most watched show
when a video of homer doing a victory
dance after winning a carnival game goes
viral
several prominent athletes hire him to
choreograph their own celebratory dances
lebron james yao ming michelle kwan
warren sapp and tom brady
all put in a request and are all voiced
by their real world selves
homer's dances grow into such a cultural
phenomenon that he wins a plum gig
organizing the super bowl halftime show
he recruits ned flanders to help him out
seeing as how his pious neighbor has
been making a name for himself by
producing violent biblical films
for the big halftime show homer and ned
recreate the story of noah's ark from
millions of football loving fans
of course the reaction of the viewing
public was pretty predictable
all over america today viewers were
outraged by the super bowl halftime
show's blatant display of religion
and decency check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the simpsons are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one